texas republican lawmakers are
attempting to restore
election integrity measures many of
which fell by the wayside during
the crazy covet election year so very
simple stuff
voter id that that kind of stuff they've
got the votes
they've got the support of the people
there is no
legal way to stop them from restoring
election integrity
so the democrat lawmakers in texas
fled the state they actually chartered a
plane
and got out of the state now the
shenanigans are not going to last
forever they can't
they're actually ending right this very
minute as i speak but it does represent
a very disturbing trend among these
democrat lawmakers
namely they have no trust in democracy
whatsoever
this goes a long way i think toward
explaining why public trust
is cratering in the media in the public
health
experts and even in our elections i'm
michael knowles that's the michael knoll
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from
duvall in the wall who says notice how
the people
that lived through communist regimes are
almost always conservative
i have noticed that i haven't we're
seeing that play out right now as the
people in cuba
are taking to the streets to protest the
regime and a bunch of libs in this
country are defending the regime
up to and including people in the biden
administration
really makes you want something
stable that you can rely on when things
get a little crazy in the economy when
inflation is a big worry as it currently
is sometimes it might make sense to
invest in
precious metals which i've really
enjoyed doing specifically investing in
physical gold now
you might say michael i don't have
enough money to invest in physical gold
right now well yes you do
because acre has an ingenious way to do
it if you've got 30 bucks lying around
you can start investing in physical gold
the way you do it is you subscribe to
their gold bars when your gold stash
reaches the price of their gold bars
acre will discreetly ship physical gold
to your
house really really great stuff it is
designed in california it is sourced
from one of the largest mints in
switzerland really good hedge
on inflation which everyone is really
worried about right now we've been
talking about it a lot
head on over right now to
getacregold.com start investing in
physical gold today make sure you go to
that url because acres giving away a
gold bar
to win the gold bar tweet or post why
you should be the recipient
and mention at get underscore acre that
is getakergold.com knowles thank you aku
gold for supporting
the show 51 at least 51 of the 67
texas house lawmakers boarded
chartered flights to washington dc so
we're talking about private jets now
to protest in support of
the corrupt politicians act this would
be hr1
and s1 this is federalizing elections
taking power away from the states
upending the constitutional system
and trying to give democrats a permanent
advantage in elections
the walkout comes after texas governor
greg abbott announced a special session
of of congress and texas texas house to
focus on legislative priorities such as
election
integrity laws so these
these democrats are absolutely immune to
irony
but if they were self-aware at all they
would
they would find some great irony in the
fact that
to protest voter id laws
they got on a bus and then on a
private jet to washington dc
in the photo that they posted from their
journey
they have a 12 pack of miller lite
which they needed an id to purchase you
so you can you're saying that we need
greater integrity around the ability to
buy
cheap beer than we do around
our democracy you know they're always
prattling on about our democracy
but then whenever we want to defend our
constitutional
structures that protect our democracy
all of a sudden they're not
interested in that sort of thing then
they get on a private jet so i can't
wait to hear them prattling on about
environmental worries they get on the
private jet
and the kicker none of them are wearing
masks
so they're telling us that we all need
to wear masks because the
kovit is the worst scariest virus ever
in the history of the world
but that filthy cloth that you put on
your face it's so super duper effective
and we've all got to wear it
even if you got the vaccine you need to
wear 15 different masks
and then they aren't wearing them how do
i know
how do i know that all of these things
happen well one they posted the pictures
but also if you or i get on an airplane
these days we're gonna have to wear a
mask because there is a federal mandate
to wear masks
on flights unless you're flying private
in which case there's no stewardess to
come up and down and yell at you to put
your mask on
the hypocrisy is so
outrageous it's so absurd it's
it's not even worth pointing out and
there's this meme going around where
people say
it's not hypocrisy it's hierarchy it's
not that
the democrats are failing to live up to
their own standard it's that democrats
believe that they
there is a different standard that they
need to play by than republicans are
that they are they are more privileged
and they ought to play by different
different rules
and that's what we're seeing happen here
and kamala harris
could not be more proud kamala harris
uh is very so the the texas lawmakers
make it to dc
they they host their own press
conference and during their press
conference
they actually break out into song we
want to be standing there
when a new voting rights act for this
century is there
and the rights that we struggled that so
many lives were taken
so much courage was demonstrated are
preserved once again
i turn it back over to you for the
questions and uh
thank you very much for all that you and
all of your colleagues are doing here
today
we will overcome we will overcome
we will never
[Music]
i cannot take any more of the boomer
larping i can
this is what's going on now is in the
1960s you had a very consequential
social movement called
the civil rights movement and it changed
the way voting took place and it changed
a lot of a lot of the country
and today
all of these it's as though time froze
in 1965 it says that everyone is just
play acting what happened in 1965
and so they're trying to compare this
effort to
br break the law in texas to stymie
election integrity reforms
to the 1960s civil rights movement or
some other really consequential movement
don't forget
these these voting laws that are going
on around the country in many
in many instances are just restoring
protections that we had
two years ago they're not even you know
we had we had election integrity
measures
then last year the liberal establishment
got rid of all of them and not all of
them but a great deal of them
and in some cases explicitly violated
the state constitution on the way
elections are supposed to be conducted
notably in pennsylvania
and now we're told that if you ever
restore any of those things again you
know those provisions that we had in
place
18 months ago if you ever do that that
that's basically
jim crow it's slavery it's racist it's
just
so preposterous not just these silly
texas democrats
kamala harris defending them i do want
to first start by
making a statement about the the
legislators
in texas who are showing extraordinary
courage and commitment i
met with them when many of them traveled
to washington d.c we
sat down and had an extensive
conversation in the roosevelt room in
the white house
and i applaud them standing
for the rights of all americans and all
texans
to express their voice through their
vote
unencumbered i will say that that they
are they are leaders who are marching
in the path that so many others before
did when they fought and many died
for our right to vote so what
what kamala harris is saying is that if
you have to show an id to vote this is a
measure supported by a huge number of
people including
by a number of polls the majority of
black people this has become a
racialized issue but but even the
majority of black people
according to many polls support these
sorts of things then
then you're disenfranchising people you
are you're disenfranchising illegal
aliens you're disenfranchising
political hacks you're just
disenfranchising people who shouldn't be
voting
that's that's what you're doing here and
she's saying that you know she applauds
these texas lawmakers
make no mistake the texas lawmakers are
subverting democracy not just because
they're
trying to get rid of election integrity
measures but because they're violating
the law
the people of texas elected their
representatives their legislators
the legislators are now pursuing their
legislative agenda
the democrats because there's no legal
way for them to stop this just flee the
state which is against the law and by
the way
uh which is going to result in there
being arrested so governor abbott came
out
he was not having any anything to do
with this he said that they're
in violation of the law the minute they
land back in texas they'll be arrested
they'll be brought back to the capitol
but that actually probably won't even be
necessary now
because a few democrats were pried off
they've now voted with the republicans
they couldn't withstand the public
pressure to do so
and the election integrity measures will
be restored
at the total
[Music]
disadvantage to all these democrats you
know
all of these democrats are are
desperately trying to prevent these
kinds of measures not just in texas but
everywhere
why what are they so afraid of why
are democrats so insistent on making
permanent the corrupt election practices
that came up
during the 2020 covid lockdowns this
isn't just happening at the state level
this isn't just happening
in kamala harris's press conferences
this is becoming a priority
of the biden administration
jensaki white house spokesman comes out
strongly against election integrity laws
he's very focused on this speech
tomorrow one that he
himself wanted to deliver he'll lay out
the moral case for why denying the right
to vote is a form of suppression
and a form of silencing and how he will
use he will
redouble his commitment to using every
tool at his disposal
to continue to fight to protect the
fundamental right of americans
to vote against the onslaught of voter
suppression laws
based on a dangerous and discredited
conspiracy theory that culminated in
assault
on our capital he'll call out the
greatest irony of the big lie
is that no election in our history has
met such a high standard
with over 80 judges including those
appointed by his predecessor throwing
out all challenges
he'll also decry efforts to strip the
right to vote as authoritarian
and anti-american as a and stand up
against the notion that politicians
should be allowed to choose
their voters or to subvert our system by
replacing independent election
authorities with partisan ones
and he will highlight the work of the
administration against this the
necessity of passing the for the people
act and the john lewis voting rights
advancement act
and how we need to work together with
civil rights organizations
to build as broad a turnout and voter
education system to overcome
the worst challenge to our democracy
since the civil war
many ironies here first of all
the use of the phrase the big lie is
is not the own that the libs seem to
think it is
what the libs are presenting is this
idea of the big lie
as being perpetrated by the nazis so
when they use this phrase the big lies a
term coined by adolf hitler
they they are comparing their opponents
to the nazis what they don't understand
though
because they didn't read the book is
that or really many many history books
at all
the big lie is a term coined by hitler
to refer to what he's accusing the jews
of doing
with regard to a general in world war
one
so unwittingly i think the democrats are
actually making themselves the nazi
the nazis in this in this analogy
furthermore
she says that the republicans are
pushing a big lie
which is all the more ridiculous because
the 2020 election
was the most secure election ever
in american history now even if you
think there was you know basically
nothing that would have swayed the 2020
election and yeah maybe there were
some issues here and there but you know
everything was totally kosher
does anybody really believe it was the
most secure election ever in american
history does anybody believe that
the expansion of widespread mail-in
votes which even barack obama a few
years ago was acknowledging
leads to fraud and abuse the
extension of of election day to election
season the
the lack of voter id at the polls
the violation of state constitutions on
election i mean
the counting of ballots after the
election i mean
even if you think the election in the
end turned out just fine
you can't possibly say that the election
was the
single most secure highest standard
election in american history
that is itself a big lie
third third and i think this is the most
important point
most voters favor these
election integrity measures according to
every survey
there's a survey just came out 78
percent
of voter we talked about this a couple
days ago in the show 78 percent of
voters
said that in addition to stronger voter
id laws they support signature
verification chain of custody controls
bipartisan observers
overseeing the counting cleaning up the
voter rolls 71 percent
said they don't believe ballots should
be accepted after election day and a
whopping 87 percent
said that they're against ballot
harvesting
so the democrats are saying that
our democracy is going to collapse
because of
election integrity measures many of
which we already had as recently as two
years ago
that the vast majority of voters support
but the democrats don't support the
democratic voice of the people and so
they're trying to undermine that with
the federalization of the elections
speaking of polls speaking of a
divergence between
what the people are saying what the
ruling liberal elite are saying
a new poll shows that 70 percent of
black voters now believe that violent
crime
is a major crisis don't forget the
ruling democrat elite says that
that rising violent crime it's imaginary
it's a racist dog whistle don't talk
about it it's white supremacy it's
whatever
well 70 percent of black voters think
it's a big problem because it's
happening in their neighborhoods right
it's not
it's not happening in you know the sunny
neighborhoods of beverly hills or
something like it's happening in
neighborhoods that have a
disproportionate number of black voters
so by the way this poll comes out from a
democrat research firm
so the the democrat firm shows
that for the first time crime ranked
ahead of the pandemic as the top issue
for all voters more surprisingly it was
an issue that voters of both parties
ranked highly 57 percent of republicans
52 percent of democrats so the majority
of both republicans and democrats
and 70 of black voters say violent crime
is a major crisis and during all of this
so you've got you've got as near a
consensus on this issue
as on any issue we have in in the united
states
the majority of everyone agrees
you got to deal with this violent crime
thing at the same time the ruling
liberal elite
which is the that's the minority group
that doesn't agree with this stuff
is actually calling to abolish the
police an msnbc host just came on
the show the beat with ari melber i get
haven't heard of this show
i was guest hosted by jason johnson uh
professor
of journalism at morgan state university
a frequent
msnbc contributor they come on and
discuss the need
to abolish the police i want to bring up
this this in the background because this
is really key
i don't think people understand how
often this same kind of violence
often visits the same families we have a
story that just came out talking about
the fact that
you know a young man who knew eric
garner later on got pepper sprayed by
the cops that george floyd's
uh you know girlfriend used to teach
dante wright the police
seem to prey on the same black people
over and over and over again i've always
made it abundantly clear i believe
abolishing police
getting rid of it entirely starting from
the beginning we've done that before
we've done it with the department of war
but in this moment that's a conversation
we can have tomorrow
you are going to hear from some more
moderate voices
in the democratic party who are trying
to win votes that abolish the police
doesn't mean abolish the police
but no defund the poll it just means you
know
reform it a little no it doesn't aoc
came out and corrected this the first
time that
democrats tried to have both sides of
the issue she said no no abolish the
police means abolish the police and
you're hearing this on msnbc too which
is
a major democrat cable network
i say it's amazing it still gets very
very low ratings but as far as
democrat cable networks go it is it is
one of the big ones
and they are outright calling to abolish
the police doesn't doesn't make a whole
lot of sense because they're saying
their argument is that the police are
brutalizing these people like
george floyd you know he was just
minding his own business committing
crimes
high on drugs hiding drugs resisting or
he was just minding his own business you
know
criminal record a mile long robbed a
pregnant woman
reportedly at gunpoint but he's minding
his own business and then the police
brutalized victimize these people and go
in and it's so
police who are very often black or
hispanic themselves it's white supremacy
though we're told
meanwhile black voters are saying
overwhelmingly no no give us more police
we want to
give the give us police so that we don't
have the violent crime
spike but there's a huge divergence here
between what the liberal ruling elite
want and what the people want you see
this most notably
with robin d'angelo's stupid book robin
deangelo is one of these race hustlers
who promotes the white fragility
anti-whiteness anti-racism
all this crazy stuff that we now we now
talk about with this label critical race
theory
um it's a it's even a little bit broader
than that or a little blunter than that
it's just
an anti-white racial ideology
so robin deangelo comes out she had this
bestseller with her first book
your second book comes out
coincidentally at the same time that my
book speechless comes out
my book so around the same time my book
outsold hers by an order of magnitude i
think at least
i i you know outsold it tremendously and
as
we've mentioned on the show the the new
york times snubbed us even though we
sold 40
more books without any bulk sales than
the number one on new york times list
robin angelo's book i think it only sold
like 3 500 copies or something like that
and they put her on the list because as
i've mentioned in my own book
the left manipulates language to try to
redefine reality and they've redefined
the term bestseller as well
and it does carry some cultural cachet
it does
influence whose books get placed in the
brick and mortar bookstores
for instance a lot of people have
written in a lot of you have written
into me and said i've gone to three book
stores in my town
and i can't find a copy of your book
even though it's number one on the
publisher's weekly list for instance
i'll say right that's just because
people are making these decisions in no
small part
based on the new york times list so we
can we joke about the new york times who
cares what they think
but they do still have cultural
influence these
radical left cable news hosts still have
cultural influence these radicals who
are
disproportionately or who are who are a
very small portion of the population
have a disproportionate amount of
political power
this is why this is why some people
don't believe the election results okay
i'm not i want to be very clear for
all of the radicals right now who are on
youtube and social media who wield
disproportionate political power and who
are going to shut this show down if i in
any way say
that the election wasn't the most secure
election i'm i'm
not talking about the election itself
i'm talking about
why people don't trust the election
those are different things and the re
the reason
that people don't trust the election is
because
the elites lie to us
all the time they lie to us about the
virus they lie to us about the vaccine
they lied to us about the masks that's
just the public health section
they lied to us about violent crime they
lied to us
about the cops they lied to us about
what's going on in cuba right now
they lie to us about everything about
everything and
they don't have any credibility they do
it they urinate on our legs and they
tell us that it's raining
and and so we just don't have trust in
them that's not the people's fault
that is the fault of the ruling elites
if you want to see someone really take
on the ruling elites i'd recommend you
check out my friend candace
candace who hosts the eponymously named
candace
you can subscribe right now
dailywire.com candace you will get 25
off new memberships with code candace
make sure you check it out you can also
check out canvas audio podcast
on spotify apple podcast stitcher google
play myspace xango live journal aol
instant messenger i don't know it's all
over the place
also you can check out ben's new book
it's a great book to pre-order
right after you have ordered my book
speechless right the minute the second
you've done that
you can pre-order the authoritarian
moment by ben i
really like this book in part because
the title is uh
also my future campaign slogan knowles
2028 the authoritarian moment
so go check that out you can you can
pre-order that wherever
books are sold we'll be right back with
a lot more
president trump just showed up to a ufc
fight
and when he walked into the stadium huge
cheers erupted
usa usa
you can see this goes on for a long time
people in the room
loved trump i mentioned this not for any
story about trump or about
ufc but because
because of this this issue that we've
been talking about
why people don't totally trust the 2020
election
they saw trump being cheered huge crowds
wherever he goes
they saw him win the 2016 election when
all the experts told us 99 chance he was
going to lose
and they see joe biden and they see that
joe biden is not
functioning even as well as he used to
and it's he was never the brightest bulb
in the pack
they see joe biden show up to campaign
events nobody's showing up you'd have 18
people in the field
they're seeing all of these election
laws magically being changed right
before the election
they're seeing in some cases illegal
outright illegal and unconstitutional
election practices
and and this is the crucial part they're
seeing
the liberal establishment continue to
lie to us
about basically everything
and and so i'm i'm not saying i am not
saying that the election was stolen i'm
not
saying that donald trump got more votes
i'm really not i'm not saying any of
that
i'm saying that it is perfectly
reasonable for people
not to believe these liars in the ruling
elite
who sneer at the majority of americans
who ignore
the preferences of the majority of
americans i mean just take this issue we
were talking about violent crime
everybody ever the majority of everybody
wants to reduce violent crime the ruling
establishment won't do a damn thing
about it and
they actually are pushing to abolish the
police look at the issue of immigration
the majority of americans want to
drastically reduce immigration
drastic legal and illegal this is a very
easy issue it's a winner it's a winner
of an issue such a winner that it
propelled donald trump to the presidency
in 2016
despite the best machinations of the
liberal establishment which was spying
on his campaign which was trying to
undermine his campaign doing lots of
nefarious
and almost certainly illegal things and
he still won because of that issue
but what's the establishment telling us
no we need more immigration
we need to send more jobs overseas and
then we need to bring in more
workers here especially low skilled
workers across the border to compete
with americans and lower their wages
that's
that's what we need right no no they
don't they just have different
priorities than the majority
of the american people they we're
we're told constantly with this
coronavirus 15 days to slow the spread
ha ha it's 18 months later whatever deal
with it twerps
wear the met don't wear the mask sheep
wear the mask sheep
put the mask on the three-year-old sheep
it's just changing constantly and now by
the way according to politico
biden allied groups including the
democratic national committee
are working with cell phone carriers to
pry
into your text messages to stop
what they call disinformation in
particular about kovid
it's not enough it's not enough that
an article in the new york post comes
out detailing corruption by the biden
family
right before the election and big tech
shuts you down from posting that but a
completely accurate report
100 true report they stop you from
posting they stop you from privately
messaging it on social media
meanwhile conspiracy theories about
trump and the russians or whatever are
promoted from the highest echelons of
power
now forget your twitter forget your face
they want to go into your text
messages because if you're texting
someone
an unapproved message a message that
contradicts the ever-changing dogmas of
the liberal regime why
that's a big problem that's a threat to
our democracy
so a handful of utterly unaccountable
people
now are going to try to go in to
to pry into your messages the goal they
say
is to ensure that people who may have
difficulty getting a vaccination
because of issues like transportation
see those barriers lessened or it's just
to help you
just for your own good isn't it
the people know that they can get a
vaccine that people know what
coronavirus is
they know that they can get a vaccine
they are not making the choice that the
liberal regime wants
and so they're going to apply pressure
dr fauci said
that that this is all horrifying that
that people who are now cheering
on certain figures in journalism and
medical science and politics who are
suggesting
maybe we can just use our prudence with
the vaccine and maybe not everybody
needs to go get it right away
fauci says this is absolutely horrifying
they were hoping the government was
hoping that they could sort of sucker 90
of the population into getting
vaccinated and it and and it
and it isn't happening right there's a
younger people i'm going to cut him off
right there because he just goes on to
just say things that are not true about
the vaccine but what i wanted
to get your reaction to is the crowd
cheering
when this gentleman talks about how the
government was not able to achieve
a 90 vaccine goal the crowd cheers
um as a public health official what's
your reaction when you hear that
it's it's it's horrifying i mean they're
cheering
about someone saying that it's a good
thing for people
not to try and save their lives i mean
if you just
unpack that for a second jake it it's
almost frightening
to say hey guess what we don't want you
to do something to save your life
yay everybody starts screaming and and
clapping
i just don't get that i mean i and i
don't think that anybody who's thinking
clearly
can get that what is that all about i
i don't understand that jake the fda by
the way just added another warning to
the johnson johnson vaccine
because of of a nerve nerve system
uh risk especially in young people
obviously there's already there was
already the pause on the vaccine because
it was causing blood clots
in in some women the mrna vaccine
has been uh it has been suggested not
just by people on the internet but by
the fda and the
cdc that it's causing myocarditis the
inflammation of the heart in
young people who face statistically very
very very
very very infinitesimally small risk
from coronavirus itself 13 year old boy
just died because of
the inflammation of the heart just a few
days after he received the vaccine no
proof yet of a correlation here
or of causation but it would it would
seem probable
it's being investigated right now so
alex berenson who was the
journalist who was speaking at the top
he says look the government was trying
to
get everyone to get this vaccine but
while some people
some groups of people are at a fairly
significant risk from covet
other groups of people are at very very
very very little risk from covid and so
they're saying
why would i get this experimental drug
that doesn't even have a full fda
approval it's got an emergency
authorization why would i get that for a
virus that poses statistically very
little risk to me
horrifying just to save your life hey
hey for all you
unwashed rube deplorable unvaccinated
idiots out there
you still alive you still you're fine
you feel good you feel okay cool good
glad
i'm glad it's a shock to dr fauci that
genius
not just on the vaccine stuff though
that has been the most recent notable
expression of the progressive
bureaucracy in technocracy
but you're seeing it in cuba cuba i
think is really putting this in stark
relief
the people in cuba protesting for
freedom protesting an end to communism
and the dictatorship
american liberals defending david
harbour who is
do you remember him he was the guy on
stranger things he's he's a big lib he
gave a
uh an award speech a few years ago
where he not not so subtly was attacking
conservatives this was after trump won
and said that he was going to punch
people in the face do you remember this
as we act in the continuing narrative of
stranger things
we 1983 midwesterners will repel bullies
we will shelter freaks and outcasts
those who have no homes
we will get past the lies we will hunt
monsters and when we are at the loss
amidst the hypocrisy
and the casual violence of certain
individuals and institutions we will
as per chief jim hopper punch some
people in the face
when they seek to destroy the meat of
the disenfranchised
yeah political violence we are going to
physically harm
our political opponents because that's
what we do in our democracy
that's that's right no civility no
legal processes we're just gonna punch
them
so that we don't become like the
fascists
what a dope so this guy this guy that
was a few years ago he comes out now and
he says
quote this is an interview just a few
days ago
i don't know that there is anyone who
could disagree with socialist ideology
i wish this was a print interview if it
were a video interview i wish
you could hear me i don't know anyone
who can disagree with socialism he says
i don't know anyone who could disagree
with socialist ideology
if you work at starbucks and you make
the coffee then you should own it you're
the one making the coffee okay so hold
on i
just uh we we don't we don't have time
on this show to dispel
the this theory of of property ownership
that if you in any way interact with
some
piece of property that then you own the
property what about the guy who grew the
beans what about the guy who transported
the beans what about the guy who roasted
the beans what about the guy
who built the starbucks what about the
guy who produced the cups
what about the guy who produced the
little sleeve for the cup what about the
person who is ringing up the customer
what about the person who laid out the
capital to start the whole thing in the
first place whether it's the farm or the
starbucks
he doesn't have much of an answer for
that he doesn't know much about anything
his first point is the most ridiculous i
don't know anyone who could disagree
with socialist ideology what about the
people in cuba right now
because you rich hollywood guy
living in america you seem to love
socialism in theory
the people living under socialism in
cuba hate it
in practice and their symbol by the way
of protest
is the american flag they've been waving
it in the streets of havana they put it
on their bicycles they sew it onto their
jeans
i saw it firsthand when i when i visited
here
the american flag is called a symbol of
oppression and hatred
there it's a symbol of freedom against
the communist
tyranny but they lie to us
they lie to us lawrence o'donnell who's
another guy on msnbc
he just came out he said you knew you
knew what was going to happen
you knew that the problem and
the problem can't be socialism because
because true socialism has never been
tried
right true commune it's never been tried
this is what we always hear
after the failure of every communist and
socialist regime in history
it's never been tried you see so you
just got to try it one more time then
it's going to work out and that is the
issue in cuba
it's not the problem is not socialism
it's the dictatorship
if the united states had been wise
enough to remove the embargo
50 years ago the cuban dictatorship
would have had no convenient excuse
for the deprivations cuba has suffered
cuba's agonies tonight are only
partially assignable to the embargo and
almost entirely the fault
of 60 years of dictatorial government
by economic illiterates cuba's problem
is not too much socialism as republicans
would have you believe
it is too much dictatorship second only
to
north korea at this point okay
it's not too much socialism it's too
much dictatorship okay
okay let's just go with that for a
second lawrence
what kind of dictatorship is it how'd
they get the dictatorship lawrence
yes there are other types of
dictatorship in the world
there are plenty of types of
dictatorship
the one in cuba is a socialist dictate
it's a communist dictatorship you say
it's like the north korea
what kind of dictatorship is that one
lawrence well no you see the reason that
the dictatorship stayed in power
is because of the united states as
punitive economic policies because we
won't trade with cuba
okay so if you're saying if we start
trading with cuba
quite a lot then the political regime
will collapse right
that was the argument for china the
argument for bringing china into the
economic mainstream bringing china into
the world trade organization
bringing china to the table and really
raising them up
as an economic powerhouse was that when
you had
economic liberalization the communist
regime would fall
that's that was what we were told the
chinese communist party today
is stronger than it has ever been before
domestically and internationally by the
way it flopped it failed this was a
policy pushed especially by joe biden
there's lots of clips of joe biden
claiming making the prediction that when
you bring china into the world trade
organization for instance
when you rise up china it's going to be
great for every country and it's going
to it's going to give more political
freedom
to the chinese people china just invaded
hong kong there's no political freedom
there anymore china's about to invade
taiwan it's going to aggress on all of
the other places in the south china sea
there they've got a social credit system
in there they're committing a genocide
in one of
their provinces china's communist
dictatorship is stronger than ever
it is not because we're not trading with
cuba
that the people are suffering it's
because of the system itself when when
the cuban people are screaming libertad
libertad
you can either believe them or you can
believe lawrence o'donnell you can
either believe the people
who are who are calling out for these
sorts of things not just in cuba but in
the united states too
or you can or you can believe the
minority
tiny ruling elite the liberal
establishment people
who are using people like lawrence
o'donnell as mouthpieces
the liberal establishment in our country
and the ruling establishment governments
around the world in cuba
in china elsewhere
have no faith in people
we obviously the cuban dictatorship has
no faith in the cuban people that's why
they don't give them any political power
and they suppress them
obviously that's true in china but it's
also true
in the united states i think to dude
they're not as successful in the united
states because we still have some
semblance of a constitutional government
but it is being chipped away at every
day most recent example
well we talked about the texans
obviously the texas
democratic legislators have such little
faith in the people of texas that they
actually violated the law
so that they wouldn't have to carry out
the the job that the people of texas
sent them to do namely to defend
election integrity
kamala harris at the at the federal
level is saying this the reason
that we need to federalize the elections
the reason that we need to upend our
constitutional system
and take away safeguards for elections
the reason that you're not allowed to
require an id to vote is because
it's it's quote almost impossible
for rural americans to in any way prove
that they are who they say they are they
they can't even go make a photocopy is
agreeing to voter id
one of those compromises that you'd
support i don't think that
we should underestimate
what that could mean
because in some people's mind that means
well you're going to have to
um xerox are
photocopy your idea to send it in to
prove you are who you are
well there are a whole lot of people
especially people who live in rural
communities who don't there's no
kinkos there's no office max near them
people have to understand that when
we're talking about voter id laws
be clear about who you have in mind and
what would be required of them to prove
who they are
of course people have to prove who they
are
but not in a way that makes it them it
almost impossible for them to prove who
they are
it's almost impossible those those dopes
those idiots
who you know those rube unwashed
deplorables who don't live in new york
and san francisco
which by the way are much filthier
places than anywhere in the middle of
the country
you know the unwashed masses they can't
you expect them to be able to use a
xerox machine
you expect hold on you're telling me
that
they're gonna have to go find a
photocopier which they certainly can but
even if they couldn't you're telling me
then if there's no
photocopy machine within 100 miles of
the people in rural america
they're going to go they're going to
need to have a printer you know that
technology that's been around for
like 40 years they're not gonna they're
they're gonna have to
do that you can get for like 20 bucks
they're gonna have to
be able to take a photo of their id
on their phones that they all have and
then
and then produce it somehow like on a
piece of paper
you can't expect that can't expect that
of them they're too stupid to do that
they're too stupid and poor and dumb and
deplorable
and that is why we need to federalize
all of the elections
and take away all the safeguards i'd
love to she
she does this thing that politicians
used to do
you know more so than now were they it's
that bill clinton thing of
well i support the opinion of the
majority but i
really sympathize with the minority you
know
like you know he just tries to have his
cake and eat it too
have a cigar and smoke it too so
she's trying to do this and she says of
course you need to be able to prove you
are who you say you are
but not in a way that's almost
impossible to almost
there there is no simpler way
than photocopying your id i'm not saying
you have to send your physical id and
not saying you need to go get a new id
not saying
just you know just put like any proof
the the only less onerous
way of submitting voter id would be like
scribbling your name in a crayon on the
back of the ballot
of the mail-in ballot which by the way
we shouldn't even have those
she doesn't have any any faith in the
people and she also she also by the way
doesn't have faith that she would win
elections if we had even the most basic
ballot measures now speaking of rural
americans we got some good news
joe biden has been pushing a farm
program that explicitly would
discriminate against white farmers the
farm program
which we covered when it when it was
first proposed
would offer major grants
for quote socially disadvantaged farmers
and ranchers defined as
black indian feather not dot or alaska
native hispanic
asian or hawaiian pacific islander and
so it would it would
get just basically give away money to to
those kinds of farmers but it would
require
farm white farmers to pay back certain
loans and so it's
obviously illegal obviously deeply
racist
and bigoted a third judge just struck
that down u.s district judge thomas
anderson of the western district of
tennessee
issued a preliminary injunction to stop
the biden agriculture department
from delivering these race-based loan
payments
uh good news this is why i say it's not
when i point out eerie comparisons
between the ruling elite and
tin pot dictatorships like cuba and here
in the united states
i do want to point out it's not that bad
yet there is still some semblance of
constitutional government there's still
some semblance
of law and order the problem is that the
left is is doing its best to
undermine them to upend all the
traditional standards at the legal level
and at the social level in the schools
especially there's a really disturbing
story out
from wisconsin wisconsin school district
a wisconsin school district is providing
sexually explicit books
to third graders uh the some of the
material teaches students how to use
sex apps these are to eight-year-olds by
the way
uh now the way this is being provided
is that the the school district is
offering students access to books and
information
via an online library that includes
books such as this book is gay by juno
dawson queer by kathy belge and merc
bish and this book is gay by the way
teaches kids how to use grinder which is
a gay sex app
so what what the defenders of this are
going to say is oh they just have access
to it but they're not being assigned
these sorts of books right they
shouldn't have access they should that's
the point i'm i'm not making an argument
for
banning and burning books explicitly
okay although that sort of practice is
looked unfavorably in both the new
testament and
uh and by plato the like one of the
founders of western philosophy but i'm
not making
that argument okay even though plato
famously called for the burning of his
of his
opponent's books my question is much
more modest
should eight-year-olds really be exposed
to everything
is a third grade classroom really a free
marketplace of ideas
i think the very thought that that would
be the case would have our founding
fathers rolling over in their graves
something tells me the majority of
people do not support explicit creepy
sex books for kids or any of this stuff
or the crazy racial theories or the
crazy gender theories or any of it
i think it's a small minority of ruling
elites pushing this stuff
the vast majority of the people don't
want it and the ruling elites
are gaslighting it about all of us which
is why we just don't trust them anymore
and
dr fauci might be horrified by that and
jake tapper might be horrified by that
and the whole ruling elite might be
horrified but guess what it's their
fault and
and they're not doing very much to
increase their credibility i'm michael
knowles it's michael show
we will get into more tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 on the matte wall show we talk
about the things that matter real issues
that affect you your family our country
not just politics but culture faith
current events
all the fundamentals if they matter to
you come check out the show